das geheimnis ewiger liebe ein
hässlicher partner wort das hat
zumindest eine harvard studie ergeben
umso attraktiver partner desto kürzer
die beziehung was dahinter steckt jetzt
eigentlich zu bekommen traue keiner
statistik die du nicht selbst gefälscht
und das gilt natürlich auch für studien
aber es scheint schon einige indizien in
dieser studie zu geben die dafür
sprechen dass die beziehungen
attraktiver menschen eher kürzer sind
als diejenigen von unattraktiven
menschen was haben die forscher gemacht
das team um christine marx allen von der
harvard university hat zunächst zwei
frauen gebeten die attraktivität von 238
männern zu vorteilen und zwar anhand
ihrer highschool fotos und zusätzlich
nahmen sie sich ganz simpel die 20
bedeutendsten schauspieler der
international movie database imdb und
die 105 bezahlten prominenten laut ford
vor doppelte wurden aussortiert die
beiden frauen beurteilten auch hier die
attraktivität und das ergebnis der
beiden versuchsreihen war ziemlich
verblüffend und eindeutig es wurde
nämlich eine probe gemacht die attraktiv
die jungs aus der high school waren 30
jahre später öfter geschrieben als der
durchschnitt und sie hatten
durchschnittlich kürzere beziehung frei
nach dem motto drum prüfe wer sich ewig
bindet ob sich was befindet und bei den
attraktiven promise genau dasselbe sie
waren kurzer verheiratet und wurden
öfter geschieht
ich finde da machen schönheitsoperation
gar kein wilder mann sollte mich sich
selbst verschönern lassen sondern den
partner hässlicher operieren lassen dann
machte das team die gegenprobe wieder
wurde die attraktivität diesmal von 130
teilnehmern beurteilt diese sollten dann
wiederum die attraktivität von anderen
menschen auf fotos vor sein und auch
diese gegenprobe funktionierte auf ihr
kann tatsächlich gefolgert werden dass
sich attraktive menschen viel schneller
trennen als unattraktive es scheint so
als auch die vermutung leicht wieder
einen neuen partner zu finden die
bereitschaft erhöht sich zu können um so
attraktiver die probanden waren desto
attraktiver fanden sie die menschen auf
den fotos die schlussfolgerung des teams
sie waren eher offen für das
kennenlernen neuer menschen und damit
auch für
eine neue partnerschaft und in einem
weiteren versuch konnte sogar
festgestellt werden wenn die beziehung
der teilnehmer fest aber unglücklich war
wie auch andere menschen attraktiver
fanden und das umso mehr desto
attraktiver sie selbst gesehen haben
also attraktivität ist wirklich ein
problem
alles in allem finde ich das ziemlich
schade wo bleibt da die romantische
liebe aber zumindest eine lösung als
partner oder partnerin sollte man sich
am besten niemand ob attraktiven
auswählen sondern lieber jemand
hässlichen ja was sollst wissenschaft
ist eben realistisch und eben auch
ernüchternd wenn er das auch findet ja
dann vergesst folgen aber wenn ihr
wissenschaft auch für das überhaupt
genial veraltet und nicht genug davon
bekommen könnt dann klickt hier auf die
besten klicks um videos in einer
playlist und drückt mir hier ein abo auf
auge dafür da klicken und nicht
vergessen mir einen auf die glocke zu
geben klickt einfach bis die schwarte
kracht oder durch bis dann